well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house I haven't said to the fact
that I'm an older person now I think 30
is when you're like watching committee
can't quit and then once the grabbers
tell someone raps a rubber band around
his mouth hey make sure that mouth is
closed
I'm really scared because I'm afraid
that a croc so embarrassed Oh would you
stop watching committee can't quit when
you got let's see
I'm really scared because look at home
fucking high I'm a teenager lookit I'm a
baby oh my god
Kim only know young I like look how I
was a baby doing this you're not
probably you later I'll bang you and
then I jerk off thanks video I'm gonna
throw up
I'm afraid that a crocodile is gonna
jump out of the water and try and bite
oh my gosh so fucking why are you
showing me this I'm so depressed
okay so you go is that I still had
under-eye bags
I'd like telling up now
there she that's so great Shane was here
a couple weeks ago he was you know what
guys he's on Twitter - why don't you go
ahead and hit him up he loves talking
about road rules
ask him road rules questions yeah he
likes uh let me give me as he remembers
like every detail of every challenge I
know it's so like you asked me about
this child you asked me about these at
at Shane SH a YN e MC b so Shane McBride
but sha YN e MC b hit him up on twitter
guys loves interactions on twitter loves
asking ask him all kinds of questions
about road rules yeah never forget
thanks for showing that tom that was
really cool of you uh well to show my
pass like that really first of all you
look amazing right you do I look like a
child it's kind of crazy how little you
look like a piece of a SS thanks that
haircut I got more emails women yeah
letters about that haircut back in the
day you love my rule rules here you're
always telling me that you want me to
get my hair cut
I love role rules here I tell you the
problem with doing that at forty what I
just look like a mom my mom you can do
that twenty and you look cool yeah forty
you look like you hate your house why
not go for a mom cut mom's here you're
an official mom now I have to wear the
culottes those jorts the moms wear some
sandals I got to cut my hair short that
a low-maintenance cut for moms saves a
lot of time it's a time saver yeah well
okay anyways that Jon and Kate Plus 8 oh
she hated him that's why she did that
that is it don't touch my post haircut
for sure you stay the fuck away from my
crotch